من الصعب تخيل مشهد مرعب أكثر
تم العثور على 39 جثة بين عشية وضحاها في الجزء
الخلفي من هذه الشاحنة النصفية شرق لندن
في المقدمة ، شوهد محققو الطب الشرعي وهم
يمشطون الكابينة ،
حيث تم إلقاء القبض على السائق ، وقد تعرف عليه عضو المجلس المحلي
باسم مارا فينسون.  25
عامًا من أيرلندا الشمالية في هذه المرحلة
، لم نحدد مكان
الضحايا من جميع هوياتهم
ونتوقع أن تكون هذه عملية طويلة ،
فهذه منطقة صناعية
ثقيلة وحتى في الساعة 1:30 صباحًا من غير
المحتمل أن  الشاحنة الكبيرة هنا
ستثير أي شك على الإطلاق ،
ستقول الشرطة فقط إنهم استدعوا هنا من قبل
خدمة الإسعاف ، 38 من أصل 39 جثة
كانت من البالغين باستثناء إحدى الشرطة التي تقول إنه من
المحتمل أن يكون المحققون المراهقون يعتقدون أن
الحاوية نشأت من بلغاريا حيث
يقول المسؤولون إنها مسجلة لدى  تقول
شركة مملوكة لشرطة مواطن أيرلندي
الآن إنهم يعتقدون أنها دخلت المملكة المتحدة عن طريق
القوارب من بلجيكا قبل وقت قصير من
اكتشافها.  د
كانت سلطات الهجرة تساعد
في التحقيق ، وذهب رئيس الوزراء إلى
أبعد من ذلك ، ويجب أن أقول إنني
أشارك الآن رغبة قوية
لمرتكبي تلك الجريمة ، وفي الواقع
كل أولئك الذين ينخرطون في نشاط مماثل
كما نعلم أن هذه التجارة
مستمرة  يجب مطاردة هؤلاء التجار
بالبشر وتقديمهم للعدالة
، لم تلتزم الشرطة بأن هذا
الاتجار بالبشر ، لكن السلطات البريطانية تقول إن
تهريب المهاجرين إلى المملكة المتحدة ارتفع
بشكل كبير من 2017 إلى 2018 ،
تم نقل الشاحنة إلى مكان آمن
لإزالة الجثث من الشرطة  نقول
لإعطاء الكرامة للحياة التي انتهت على ما يبدو
دون الكثير على الإطلاق
سكوت ماكلين سي إن إن غراي إنجلترا